hello and welcome to our monday night
show i hope you are alright it's a
little bit later four minutes late yeah
I had a lesson that took a little bit
longer than originally planned so like
five minutes it is okay guys how are you
being in the chat yeah got some regular
um guys on there wasn't any bilbao
coverage today i'm happy to say that i'm
going to do another broadcast of the bow
on wednesday so looking forward to that
so let's see if i can get some good
games going in the five-minute pool i
know that my rating is pretty down so i
have chances to increase it but you can
always lose even from low ratings and a
pretty busy day so i hope that the
pairing system is somewhat kind to me
not giving me grandma's like every game
i would be kind of kind of helpful so
i've requested a five-minute game i will
also i'm starting have a look okay ultra
runner is the first opponent I'll stick
to my my guns here yeah oh the Kings
gambit right in the first right in the
first game and what am I going to do
with that said let's play classical
stuff yeah this is a good line for black
that is easy to learn this is why I'm
going for it yeah I know I don't
remember what's going to what's
happening here I think he wants to go
see form so what I what am I doing here
i think see
right I can't remember ok I don't
remember it exactly it's been a while
since I studied this this one yeah does
he have c4 coming up 96 there might be
c4 right ok I'll take this so I was
thinking Bishop c5 not sure about this
oh yeah he probably will unpin and then
I'm not quite sure what i'm doing but
let's move let's play this first play
first think later or something like that
yeah yeah night takes is 6 i'm not sure
how much of a threat this is i think i
just cancel him maybe it's a threat but
i mean i have III as well ok I'll joanna
is playing and very quickly here he
wants to get to this exponent then it's
hard to avoid them really hard to avoid
it takes c3 evil take is six hmm Jim not
so happy about that I move the night it
also doesn't look very good night III he
will take its X ok i'll i'll grab this
check it is a good question who's got
more pressure the higher rated player or
the lower rated player um yeah I usually
feel quite comfortable when I'm the
underdog I don't feel like I have to
prove anything so I'm
I don't know it depends on the stakes
made grind assets I think this is
probably true it really depends a bit on
what what the game is all about now if
the higher rated player needs to let's
say wind to get an important price or
qualification for for a turn for for
something you might have more pressure
so ultra runner has gotten this porn so
I'm going to trade here Mario asked if
I'm able to play blind chess against
multiple opponents I've never tried to
be honest never tried I'm pretty sure
though that I can I can play against
some opponents like three should work ok
so what to do here can I go 95 he or
something I would like to get some
something going at is king it says it's
slightly slightly shaky all that stuff
oh all pieces are unprotected he's also
playing very quickly the sky yeah I was
you know just as easy but not for me oh
ok
yeah I'd like to get 94 and now that
would be it would be helpful matcha for
it what's the deal rook f2 almost almost
in he's got this Queenie aid stuff I
can't shake him here on f2 and it
doesn't lead to much okay Brooke Luke f2
and what happens there he just has he
just has given up on the e-file am I not
just winning now what what is the thing
here white resigned yeah yet sometimes
it makes sense to spend some time before
moving and he played like instantly most
of the time tricky position I probably
wasn't trouble here well okay I haven't
played a blitz game since last week so I
have to really get into the starting
thick of things Grandmaster L marmalade
yeah elma mug aroma let's see what is
going to play sometimes he plays real
crazy stuff sometimes it plays very good
normal chest let's say I've got an
English opening here and let's see what
we get I like this for while I think
white has a slight advantage in those
slides but i'm not an expert only
experimenting with the English opening a
little bit lady lately
it did take certs unusual let's say okay
I'll take this yeah i think korea v I
played some guys while cycling it on on
some kind of yeah I am honor honor
what's what's the what is it called oh
no no no on a cardio or something is the
name I don't really know how this is
called which he got in though some in
gyms okay I'm not sure III was the right
move to be perfectly honest but you'll
see what happens
the upcoming English video series Jessa
about words for white it's a wide
repertoire check so let's see that this
cannot be particularly great what he did
to be honest I think that I should get
the sea for poor now with a very good
position black resins you just resigned
this is pretty early I mean blacks
position is very bad very bad but still
at very early resignation yeah I think
he shouldn't have played the c5 move ok
I'm going to redress the numeric yen's a
man that's probably referring to young
team on right is a dutch guy yeah I've
gained a couple of points it's nice yen
the man I don't even have a good scoring
and so fifty percent so gotta Trump
looks a bit like the London system now
so we'll see I have to have to take
first ok anyway it's not a big deal this
is pretty ok um ok Bishop 26 yeah he
wants to play every move instantly and
it's mean it's a very simple position to
play so it's it's doable so yeah mmmm
what did you ever think about e5 in this
position but the coil structure is a
little bit on the weak side yeah I can't
play Bishop e7 let's do that this is
like it's a simple smooth I was thinking
if I could do something more interesting
but probably not I don't don't don't mix
jump off ski with Donald Trump and I
won't discuss it on the Trump on that
stream I had people complaining about
that so I won't do that anymore so e5 I
tragically for winning a piece okay oh
that's interesting stuff interesting
stuff what happens here he wants to play
like Queenie form okay 95 Queenie fours
the thing
yeah I can take these three right and
take d5 ok yeah I want to keep my
opponent and yeah I often play one
Knight f3 or c4 as a transposition of
weapon yes against the groom fella
benoni yeah George is nailing it this is
why i'm playing Knight f3 quite often
black cannot take d for here because of
B should be six I will try to keep this
pawn and I don't want to see f6
happening
okay then I don't quite know way wants
to go with this to eat or maybe check
that seems to be the idea but mmm I've
got I window in lots of time here right
and rook c8 and stuff and here just our
keep t4 i won't give this up so easily
my queen doesn't have many squares this
is a bit of an issue where to where to
goon it look like a sick so much that
makes my bishops unstable well but this
is kind of a moot point white also has
to find something first rook f4 okay
I'll just push this way Scott Drew k for
an hour can you believe this bouquet for
trapping my queen I didn't see it oh my
god ah I was close that was really
really close so what am I doing here
Queen f7 i canno g8 okay I'll kick this
back oh wow
96 here we go but I should have some
counter player as well you've got a week
background isn't there some way to use
that ok I go there and see what happens
ok so what to do here night f7 is the
thing is the thing here yeah ok I'm
going to take f5 at the end 42 is pretty
strong
check okay and I wanted to take at five
now but maybe I've got something better
you can take be seven maybe sir could be
a problem where should the bishop be on
e5 maybe cannot take a two unfortunately
queen e 5 is a good mover threatening
creature you one let's do that okay you
found a defense let's take it let's take
this
whoa tough business him what is what is
this what what am i threatening him
maybe like Quincy to Roxy for okay well
I could actually take the next pawn here
or what is the deal rook c8 is this idea
okay that could be improved by morning
Oh create I know it doesn't work
actually I can take you six so you can
only win by tactics now against my king
I've got so many pawns it's pretty hard
here pretty hot
president windy one here check
okay that should be should be enough
check check check white for fits on time
okay that was a tough fight so let's see
ya this English this will be g three
most of the time I'm not quite sure
what's villas jest there and that very
serious i have to have to check this
it's really fire people request the sh
lactose laughs I don't really know why
this is so boring it's solid yes but
it's so boring okay yeah i think i'm
mostly luckier with those three wins in
starting oh my way with black so we will
have them the scotch this one f4 Wow
wow that looks risky that looks risky
how to do that not clean edge form yeah
we group the a problem
haha its other account got banned to the
guy sir requesting the schlechter sloth
okay it's cool okay so rook da died
guess qjf three year it really looks
strange but can you can can black refute
it what he did yeah hmm I don't want to
go back I definitely don't want I want
to do it more than Emma Claver probably
won't look so I have to go back very
interesting I've had many interesting
games with my way I could lower many
questions what's my favorite Frank
Sinatra song that's difficult actually
like his stuff um I really I really
don't know I really remember this this
movie catch me if you can and they had
fly me to the moon when Leonardo
DiCaprio personated pilot I really
remember that one it was really really
great sequence what do we have can mvl
keep the second place in over 2800 why
not why not he's a very strong
enterprising player and had very good
results lately h4 here by my way for
Bishop g5 on age 6 he might still no he
cannot play it on age 6 but I don't know
if age 6 helps me
let's do it I'd ask him again what he's
doing Christian nunez us how often do I
play study chest day and often hunt well
um well I'm a professional teacher so
I'm doing I mostly teach other other
person's my students and I don't really
do that much for my own game simply
don't have time but if you ask me how
much time I spend on shares like
everything if there's really not much
else then I do okay yeah no Queenie
seven I need anything night out that's
what I what a difficult position yeah i
would like to complete the c-45
repertoire that i started for my channel
i really would like to but i'm not sure
when to find the time
you
okay so i can take at five now yeah i
think he he thought he came to the
conclusion that he needs to get place
hold yeah i think i think i need to take
a five almost I was neat after almost
all night have six food yeah i think i'm
taking this now i have not yet done this
is this kind of recording a lesson like
other streamers have done but one of my
students has recorded our lesson so and
they should be available on twitch I
think it's on twitch mmm he's got Queen
g3 coming up I can also go Bishop g6
here I Scott h5 while right what did
terribly terribly complicated position
Queen g3 is very irritating here
you
now the album count again but I won't
play I am and this is just too bad i
mean okay speaking about too bad this
position is super tough super-tough he's
really playing well nitey for is coming
up I guess I am I've ever Bishop g5 oh
my god oh my god I totally forgot about
Bishop g5 here or age 5 is terrible oh
my god yeah I'm just lost oh my god I
know what a bad move age 5 it was very
tough to play anyway but now it now it
just lost year I have no moves time
morning ah what is shame what is shame
it was a very interesting position
and my way is very creative technician
you can always lose against him it
happened to me before I mean his opening
was very likely incorrect very likely
but it's a yeah it's one thing to play
an incorrect opening and the other two
refuted actually I'm not lost here
interesting yeah why is my way rated
like that in not high i think it's he's
a very creative player but sometimes it
just doesn't work I mean I have a huge
plus score and the four reason I think
okay so this is actually still
interesting I don't know about this but
boom 96 what the beep it wasn't a clear
position at all and I'm blundering the
bloody exchange oh my god it wasn't it
wasn't cleared all due to the time but
now it is fairly can yeah playing fancy
stuff low check check
check check check unfortunately that's
not a chick made yeah okay I'm resigning
this is there was disappointing I was
disappointing I don't believe in that
opening one bit about but anyway okay
start so when next game yeah I'm playing
against blue bear that's a new opponent
instead a new handle no it's not it's an
old handle but I never play them little
bear so okay I'm going to play three
year against this again i QP pollution
check yeah this is the only way to
challenge like set up here we'll see I
mean black is ok if he knows his stuff
but it's not so not totally simple so
we'll see how he's handling this shoot
you for okay slightly risk him
ok ok one doesn't do the trick let's do
let's do this it must be the easiest
position ever here check
a force not winning yet
who jumped its no no direct way to
refute this stuff it seems least I don't
see it
least I don't see it as there should be
some refutation of this but I don't see
yeah tick-tock tick-tock my time Mikey
nice excited is strapped it's trapped
okay whatever check so well after him
yeah I mean that wasn't good yeah that
should have been refuted somehow but I
couldn't couldn't make it work okay 95 I
guess check check
yeah I ponds are not coordinated well
otherwise it would be kind of
interesting at least but doesn't really
work unfortunately check I've got some
kings at once but they are not mobile I
only hope is that my opponent is playing
like every move instantly and I mean and
one point you're going to play some
nonsense sir if you do that so I have to
open that but I really did review this
strange King excursion there over all
over to them and to the to the Kings
side check
you
check yeah it looks like Al awesome Wow
no big chances here with my horns Jeff
Chang he really irritated me a lot with
this with this instant movie I'm every
move instantly how does he stop that
pondan show me King takes eight seven
how does he stop it check
check check check time warning can
object will win him fortunately check
gain crown really would have liked to
swindle this yeah yeah because it is
this is this is just not good this is
just crazy is this way of playing there
is no way to refute this huh crazy okay
so let's go for a new game so yeah it's
not I mean it's not like the album's
counter gambit this loose yeah but white
is better with a three or night BTW too
i made a video on that star and i think
this is quite convincing okay so a
stroke what is a stroke doing I'm
playing a little bit of this for stuff
that I recently studied check let's not
be too quick here
getting out of the b5 mover at Whitby
fire he still wants to play it okay hmm
is that really good cheer for black I
wonder about the timing of all this here
I've got the a foul him okay let's see
mmm interesting we should have four
maybe okay it's bishop this 693
not quite sure him what to do was it
show everybody should be seven hours so
it's easier for him to get this in
I came back here at least that will be a
tempo on the bishop later with 93 yeah
this is so I think a good opening result
here for a white skipping this all the
way okay I don't like to go to be one
but i probably have to
okay so we probably go back to c6e am
now that looks that looks quite solid
him what to do what to do and I leave
five could be something but this is a
temple
hmm interesting yeah at stake here I
wonder ever have some discovered eight
years yet some some tactics on the long
diagonal you know could be quite
interesting to see hmm how to do this
here I mix the night and just trade hmm
now Queen a one could be a move actually
okay let's do this i'm not quite sure
the strengths to take take be five yeah
it's i'm trying to use this better
development here okay queenie one is a
bit strange a bit um it tries to trade
one of the better pieces that black has
the Queen okay yeah this is this as
possible but it takes time it takes time
hmm don't quite see probably move the
rook somehow but we're rookie one trying
to play you forward he has before as
well let's do it okay I cannot chick
with the night this is not exactly a
difficult move to cso didn't really
evaluate it correctly right then that is
got a five day as well wow what did i do
here anyway
a Yeti five potentially okay let's make
sure that I'm not directly losing
material him it's not exactly what I
wanted but
time warning Wow
not a good development I just had a
better position 10 moves ago and totally
screwed it up and I've got no time on
the clock amazing I thought 22s got 94
there or bishop f2 wow I'm looking like
a total [ __ ] in this game absolutely
yeah it's all easy he has to play easy
moves all the time
36 seconds oh my god I probably has some
kind of winner but he will certainly
show me he played a great game anyway
into ahead of zero out of two against
the sky so probably very strong player
hair looks you to everything instantly
okay check check check yeah great play
by my opponent absolutely what forfeits
fun time yeah I mean I I really played
that badly the opening position was good
but I totally did not get it right okay
so let's see yeah there's a new book
coming up a Boris Gelfand didn't dynamic
decision-making and chest the book
before that positional positional i
think it was positional decision-making
in chess was excellent probably the best
book of i think it was released last
year so on and heavily recommended
really wonder when I screwed up here I
mean that dead position out of the
opening must have been quite ok at least
I mean no angel beliefs like a spider
cool amazing Jay I have to improve
somewhere here I mean it cannot be bad I
think he lost some time in the opening
maybe 95 is good here I need to maybe
really force all those trades tough
tough business again sadly Mateo 02 is
the game now let's see you I have not
played up yet
so or the Evans gambit yeah this is one
of the good lines against this opening
it's still are tricky to play especially
in very
okay let's trade stuff in so I have to
be a bit a bit cautious here definitely
let's see a queen am Bishop a 3 as
always possible here yeah just look very
easy here and rook the one is coming hmm
i don't like that too much here i
usually play Bishop e7 but i wanted to
try this one hmm did I do something
wrong maybe it looks difficult for me
here to play this position ok it looks
very day very very dangerous iam I want
to be ready to play Bishop c5 a team
prevents that yeah wow whoa the debt
that's very dangerous here wow luke t 1
is the move that is going to be the big
issue here I can go nite age 6
poor rock do you one hey I will play
Queen g4 Danya it's hard to believe that
this should hold 92 what would what is
that I mean I can't take this but I
cannot take this night it said winning
then you could give one Queen f-for my
ghost then I don't see it it I mean it
it's very dangerous but still he did not
just blunder this night I mean I cannot
believe that but I don't see what he's
doing I don't see how it wins sacrifices
24 you know Queen a for Queen B for
maybe just win I can go back to a 6 ok
show me I mean if he has a win here then
all the check power to him oh I didn't
see this move at all if the day is it so
dangerous like Bishop g7 Queenie five
there should be six and i can go clean d
7
check yeah it's where's mckuin going
does he did you trap my queen with all
this stuff I came down Bishop f2 it will
just move it move the king Nyjah for
counter-attacking he will take on g7
dinosaur thing f6 escribi seven layers
Queenie seven anyway mmmm huh wow so he
will play Queenie some creatures that
made me with made me on the parties is
the problem here
I have no I have no move in this
position shoot i will check maybe it was
just good it was just good what you hear
twin desertion run ELQ wind eh I made
yep checkmate very nice very nice yeah
you probably shouldn't play this line if
you don't know it well in the Blitz game
but should be seven is my my normal move
here but I mean this is the best move
but you have to know stuff maybe I did
take 27 which is what what is what kind
of move is that he canceled instead of
queen bee three I have to react to that
I have to come clean f 6m and I'd have
six here right I just didn't think I
just didn't think here and the thing is
after this like has to do this move and
he's okay after that but he cancelled
and now I don't need Queen yourself I
can just develop I think yeah this is
what i need to do 27 mate doesn't make
any sense at all only in this context I
mean here wow this is like super
difficult to play yeah yeah I've already
lost to the engine gives gives a loss
here already and yeah this is a this is
not necessary and thought rook to e1 but
92 is clever I just said okay show me
she will be five I didn't really see but
it's it's losing check it's losing yeah
yeah I have no move I mean I can take
your head of course just King edge one
and there is no I have no way to cover
this
stuff here yeah I made a bad opening
move their queen to d7 is pretty
embarrassing and after that i'm
basically toast okay game 1 one more
game please um what do we have ok I'll
go uh huh no draw offered I mean ok if
you don't have time to play you can
afford it I'm not against that I'm not
should not just in donating three points
to you or something why is he doing him
just take the board if you for some
reason cannot play I mean sometimes it
happens say you request the game in the
pool and then someone shows up at your
door or things like that so yes I don't
really mind that but now what's now is
letting the clock run down or what what
kind of person are you
okay so we just let the clock run down
now yeah what to do oh how it plays the
move okay let's see if I can play this a
bit better than the white game before
which was really atrocious what I did so
we get a tirage it be three let celina
recently looked at but I wouldn't really
say that I know it I only started with
the examination there III the ideas 92
and potentially night f4 rook see one
also comes into consideration here yeah
yeah you could have aborted i offered
him in the board
yeah i have i've had this myself a lot
unit something happens and you cannot
really play the game so this is when
when they offer a quick draw I just
usually offered that board I mean it can
happen so let's see here isn't this some
bit tricky for him now you ever just
take the draw I lose a couple of points
and I really don't see why I should do
that even doing the board this is kind
of friendly or offering that okay yeah
I've thought about this but I couldn't
really believe it and take here first
Knight f6 I go back to f3
hmm okay
it's a very strange game and always
taking ages in this position I mean it
says something cool to do this one day I
can I can take on h5 that's what I was
thinking but this is actually maybe not
that great Bishop takes before then
could be tricky I don't have I don't
have many squares is the thing ok I
think I have to take this anyway and
think about it next it's not clear here
right or is or am I not seeing stuff
after Bishop cheeks or even Queen takes
might be a move yeah Bishop takes ok how
to play here he's got this discovered
checks i would like to get out of this
of course king edge to it this runs into
new checks and if I take F to Bishop
takes King takes there's Queen d2
amazing so what to play here
I don't really see a good movie i mean
i'm not sure what he threatens maybe 94
here and idea for probably is the threat
don't see a good move them I just don't
push up d fire to counter take one f7
okay I have to play something i don't
really know i'm quite tired yeah they
cannot really figure it out this gives
me also g2 as a square this was one of
the ideas am
check look f2 it's got something or
something to g5 coming up okay anyway
let's let's play a move him okay Queen
f8 is not possible well this is a dear
chief five or something I can also go
back here now all right should take
screen changs
Queen age 3 is the idea on what's the
idea shoot
the f file doesn't look very safe but I
need to threaten something here Queenie
late I think I've saved it check Queen
evade is almost made almost black
forfeits on time ah oh yeah I was there
was a really crazy game at the end of
this session whoo it's tough okay i hope
you enjoyed this wild ride had a couple
of wins at the beginning and then I lost
the couple yeah definitely um I kind of
up and down session yeah I hope you
enjoyed it was some tough games in there
and yeah that's the final live stream
for like three weeks the three weeks
yeah i'll be back on the fifteenth of
august yeah so it will be it adds almost
four weeks right yeah it's a long time i
hope you enjoyed it make sure to join me
again when i'm back mid august from my
tournament and vacation bye bye guys
you